when i talk about why i got trapped in
it is it's ridiculously accessible
internet pornography is just everything
on steroids what
kept me in it was the shame when i talk
about porn addiction i'm talking about
not wanting to watch porn promising
myself that i'll never watch porn again
and then feeling un is uncontrollable
urge to go back and i do
it consumed my life so it started taking
up more and more time more and more
energy and then me pushing the
boundaries going from pixels to people
but when i peeled back the onion and i
said what am i going to porn for
i'm going to hit on girls less i'm going
to approach them less i'm going to
interact with them less
if you're married and you're watching
too much porn it creates a distance
between you and your wife
if you want xanax you have to go to get
it from somebody for a couple dollars a
pop but if you want to
you know porn you're you're two seconds
away from having it the dealer sitting
right in front of you at any time it's
magnified for kids we do so much to
protect kids from alcohol from
everything under the sun and then what
do they have to do they have to check
mark that they're 18.
porn addiction it's a real issue matter
of fact 40 million adults in the u.s
visit
internet porn sites on a regular basis
one in five every internet search on
mobile devices or pornography
men who are happily married are 61 less
likely to look at porn
20 of men admit to viewing pornography
at work
and 88 of porn scenes contained physical
aggression
49 contained verbal aggression my guest
today
is an entrepreneur ceo running a
successful business and one day he
decides to go talk about his porn
addiction
and he doesn't just do it on a small
platform with five of his friends or
maybe his relatives maybe his mom dad
he decides to do it on this place called
ted talks
he gives a speech nearly three million
people find out
about his addiction and that led to a
lot of different dialogue so with that
being said
ellie nash thank you so much for being a
guest on valuetainment
thank you patrick thanks for having me
big fan of your work i appreciate that
i'm glad to have you on because uh i
think it's fair to say
this is an issue that comes up uh
amongst
men all the time but they're embarrassed
to talk about it and i get a lot of
random calls
on how to handle this so you know prior
to getting into it you know one
just basic question for you so when you
want to give the talk you've got
millions of views
you're on a successful business in miami
what were some of the
you know commentary you got from people
that are close to you family friends
co-workers
kids that knew you in high school in new
york i mean jewish community
what were some of the reaction got from
people that you know the people closest
to me
reacted reacted pretty well for the most
part right
some of my family i'm not sure what they
think they've said nice things to me i'm
not sure what they're saying about it
behind my back
in business i've had sometimes mixed
reactions so i
i was once trying to get uh do business
with a big client i won't name them in
here you got a big audience
and i had a few good calls and then the
line went dead
so i followed up with someone the person
who put me in touch i said hey can you
try to figure out what have
what happened with this uh with this guy
because i had some good calls with him
and what had happened is the company
looked me up and saw
something about porn and said hey i
don't know if we want to do business
with him i'm not sure what the deal is
with the whole porn addiction thing but
i'll give you another
story that happened a couple of weeks
ago this guy do business with for
10 years one of my more important
relationships and we're at dinner he has
a
little bit of wine in him and he says
elias want to let you know it's such an
honor to do business with you from all
the people i do business with
it's a real honor to do business with
you so i said you know
why do you say that you know i
appreciate it but why do you say he's
like what you've done on that porn thing
he's like and a lot of people struggle
it struggle with it including me
he's like that's just it's so cool that
you
uh put that out there like that and i
didn't expect it i didn't expect it from
him
so i've gotten mixed responses but i
would say between the two
it's much more important to me that
someone that that does business with me
values it than someone who's
never met me now ellie i think it's
important for people to realize
you know you you start a company uh
called mike drop with you and
rush lowe right i don't know if i'm
pronouncing his rain right i hope i'm
pronouncing that right
can you kind of give us the optics give
us some perspective of how big the
business was
and your level of success was when you
decided to go public with this
how successful were you guys at the time
so mike drop is a second business that i
started more recently
somewhat of a passion project there's a
business that i started in 2006 with
this which is a distribution business
that's correct yeah okay that's a
distribution business and
we've been doing it since 06 like i said
at the time of the ted talk we probably
had about
80 employees um doing north of 100
million in business a year
and mike drop was something that i had
done because
get this patrick i had a painful fear of
public speaking
get out of here really painful fear of
public speaking and the guy who helped
me get over it
was rash low rash low is a local
was a local news reporter for channel 7
local to miami
so he helps me to to speak a different
talk i gave on child sex abuse sharing
my story
within the community and then i tell raj
hey i want to
start this as a business i saw the
impact it had on me and on a lot of
people that i introduced it to
i found it as one of the best teamwork
things i've ever done in my company is
to have him come in
and train people to tell their story and
get over that fear of public speaking
so that's how that business started
pretty powerful and the reason why i
want the audience to know that is
because you're not just like somebody
hey let me go out there and
you talk about 80 employees a hundred
million dollars a year that's not like a
that's a
you know it's very hard to run a hundred
million dollar your company most people
get to a million ten million five
million a hundred million dollar your
company
and you say i want to get out so walk me
through what happened when you went up
to your partner and said hey i'm
thinking about doing this what was his
initial reaction to you
so so here's what happens um i i
approach him
about starting a business helping people
tell a story i say why don't you leave
channel seven do this full
time it's amazing i saw the way it
changed my life i feel like i have a
voice
it was something i brought to my
employees as well i said let's let's
turn this into a company
so after he started his business he goes
into he starts doing a few different
projects and i say hey let's do it again
by us so the first time we did it was
while he was still at the newspaper and
i s this the business we started i
believe was 2019 or end of 2018
i said let's bring it back and let's do
it again in our company
and one of his secrets i guess that he
offers is the ceo should always speak as
well
don't just have the company do the talk
also have the ceo talk
so he asks me what do you want to talk
about and i say i know exactly what i'm
talking about
i'm talking about porn addiction and you
should have seen his face
[Laughter]
the reason why this was a big deal we
have to frame this correctly patrick
this guy is a guy who encourages people
to share their story that's who he is
his job is training people to tell their
story so he's trained people
and as a news reporter he's trying to
get the story
and when i tell him that i want to share
my story on porn addiction
the story guy the story guy tells me you
can't do something
yeah that's why it was such a big deal
and that's what clicked for me i said if
i can't tell the story to him
him of all people is telling me i can't
say the story
i got to do it from the biggest stage
and that's when i decided i'm doing a
ted talk on point addiction
so so now that was done ted talks went
live with your porn addiction video
june 24 2019 i'm assuming that's not the
day you gave the talk it's probably a
month prior to that or two months prior
to that
and it's at two months prior to that
okay so 2.683 million
what has women's reaction been to this
you know let's
men is a different story hey bro i'm so
glad i've been struggling with them
myself as well
or you know and maybe they don't even
want to talk about it they're
uncomfortable
but what have women in your life said
about
your uh you opening up regarding
escaping porn addiction
so the two most important women in my
life my wife and my mom have been
extremely supportive
of it very very very supportive my wife
in general
takes it as a um a huge plus
she says i trust my husband more than uh
because you know i'll be honest i spoke
about porn addiction there but
here we're having a conversation and i
went from pixels to people right it got
porn addiction became a problem for me
that was beyond that
was beyond porn itself and uh
being a recovered sex addict so to speak
a recovered porn addict
my wife takes that as a source of pride
as far as she's concerned and that's one
of the things that gave me the pride to
to speak up about it and my mom as well
she just thinks it's awesome that i've
uh
that i'm willing to talk about it she
understands that i'm doing it to
to help others i you know i was i wish i
heard it from someone else
about porn addiction while i was stuck
in it and that's why i talk
so that someone else i know i know the
pain of of porn addiction and that's i
speak to those people
i speak to what i needed to to hear
women outside of that
i don't know i'm not talking to i'm i'm
a married man man
good answer well i get i get messages
every once in a while on instagram
from women who are addicted to porn not
a ton but i do
and i just wonder you know when we talk
about the scale with men like you're
reading the statistics at the beginning
it's almost every man but let's say with
women it's one in four women or one in
five women that have
that watch pornography a lot it could
also be a big problem
there i don't know the scale of it on
the woman's side is what you're saying
you don't know the scale of it yeah
but i have received anecdotally i've
received messages from women who say hey
i'm addicted to porn and it's really
hard for me to say anything about it
so yeah the fact that you said there's
only two women you know the most
important women in your life your wife
and your mom
uh if you're a sex addict it's good to
be a sex addict while you're married
because you're addicted to having sex
with your wife so i'm sure that benefits
your spouse which is a very good thing
your wife is
lucky to be married to a sex addict
that's a good place to be now
for men okay i run a sales organization
i was in the military in the army you
know i had a sergeant in the corner
who was the king everybody looked at
this guy they admired him they just
admired the hell out of this guy
and i'm an 18 year old kid i've been
there for a little long now obviously
you know as a kid my mom caught me under
the mattress with my best
high quality porn addiction from hustle
magazine whatever i had had the nice
stash
high quality and hidden in the right
places she found it one day
and uh you know she was uh she was
shocked by it i said what what would you
like me to have you want me to have
naked pictures of what here
you know girls man you know animals what
would you like me to do here i'm
i like women so we had a different
reaction but there was the judgment you
always kind of feel like there's a level
of
judgment now i go in the military the
guy in the corner
if i the mountains of porn vhs tapes he
had
was incredible and everybody would
always go to a street and i wonder why
is everybody going there and we found
out today we're going to look at this
today we're going to look at that
fast forward to me running a business i
cannot tell you how many times i've
walked into one of my sales guys
and they're sitting there and all i hear
is oh you know the
sound in the background and they're like
trying to close the window like bro what
are you doing bro we got clients here
a few months ago a very funny experience
happened because one of my employees
uh i said hey you know where we at with
this image that we got to put up for the
thumbnail
he says here let me show you the
thumbnail i have it right here he takes
his phone out proudly
shows me the phone as he's going through
it he forgot to close the window of his
porn the penetration's taking place
he was so embarrassed he couldn't talk
to me for a couple weeks good news is
he's still an employee of ours he hasn't
been fired for appointment
he what what is it with men
being addicted to porn and why is it
that it's such a bad thing for men to be
addicted to porn
as i always speak from personal
experience i can't speak for
forever that's that's what i'm bringing
here i mean you can always have a
psychologist who
comes as well or a scientist i come from
personal experience so first of all i
want to say i'm not an
anti-porn advocate there are many
anti-porn advocates
if it's working for someone god bless
them it didn't work for me i'm coming
from that perspective
it's it may not work for anyone it may
work for everyone but me it's not my
business
but when i talk about why i got trapped
in it is a
it's ridiculously accessible
ridiculously accessible
but the second and also i mean there's
some you know we
like women and i like women and that's
all you see the pictures and
it's there's a there's a lot there and
they get better and better at it right
when you talk about the magazine
um it's it's not the same problem
there's an organization called fight the
new drug
and pornography which combats
pornography or gives information about
pornography
and they consider it a new drug even
though pornography is as old as time
itself
because internet pornography is just
everything on steroids
like when you're done with that hustle
magazine or whatever it is you were
looking at
to get another one you got to go i don't
know how old you were at the time but
you got to work to get that next
magazine especially if you're under 18
as a teenager i mean it's just right
there at your fingertips more and more
and more and more so the variety and the
accessibility and for me
uh what kept me in it was the shame and
when i talk about porn addiction i'm
talking about not wanting to watch porn
promising myself that i'll never watch
porn again and then
feeling un is uncontrollable urge to go
back and i do
so and i what the difference for me and
what kept me in there
what changed what's the real variable
that changed is shame
is talking about it so i was in therapy
for five years talking about other stuff
and intense things i was sexually abused
as a child and that was
a lot of the work i was doing in therapy
and i lied to him about the fact that i
was watching pornography for five years
so what does that tell you about the
average guy who's struggling with porn
we may be comfortable watching it and
talking about it but if we're trapped
in it can we turn to someone and ask for
help and that's what
that's what it took for me to get out of
it and that's one of the main reasons i
speak so that if someone else
is having a hard time saying no shame
there's a lot of us
who've been there and there's a way out
and the way out is through combating the
shame
so so what what but if you go a little
deeper i mean i'm on the website that
says the 12-step
program to get uh uh you know stop
watching porn and you know i'm on the
website as well they just talked about
fight the new drug
um this is something where i get uh a
lot of calls uh of myself as a guy that
runs a company with twenty thousand
agents i get a call from wife sometimes
saying hey can you every once in a while
talk to the man about porn addiction
i don't want you to bring up the name
but you know i've caught my husband
watching porn a lot and
et cetera so a lot of these things come
from the women's side as well
on you know i i don't want my husband to
watch porn because he can't stop
watching porn right
but to go kind of a little bit deeper
what is the challenge like what is the
problem of watching
porn i can speak from the experience
from my behalf and what i've read on it
myself when i'm studying what the
challenges of this is for both were
single man
and married man but for you what was the
challenge of watching too much more like
what kind of negative effects did it
have on you
it consumed my life so it started taking
up more and more time more and more
energy and then me pushing the
boundaries like i mentioned
going from pixels to people but when i
peeled back the onion and i said what am
i going to porn for
right which this is a that's really the
question someone has to
ask them for i'll give i'll give you a
great story so i get a call from a kid
who finds me on facebook
and he's struggling a lot because he's
21 22 years old and he's tried and
failed
uh to stop porn multiple times different
promises different
uh filters on his computer everything he
sees my talk he reaches out to me said
dude i've tried everything and failed
uh maybe you can maybe you can have a
call with me so i said sure i get on the
phone with him and the first question i
ask him is
why do you watch so much porn and he
says to me because i'm a guy
so i said so you're telling me that the
reason you're going to porn every single
time the reason you're going to porn
is strictly for a physical sexual need
that's what you're looking to get from
it
and he said yeah i think so i said okay
obviously i didn't believe that to be
the case because that wasn't the case
with me
and this is i think the kicker right so
as we continue the conversation i said
hey just tell me when it got the worst
when did when did your porn use get so
bad that you said i'm done or tell me
what's going on now that you decided to
message
me on facebook because that's not easy
to do to reach out to someone and have
this conversation
so he says oh i finished school i think
he was in college i came back home
i'm back in my parents house my one of
my siblings was dealing with an illness
i think it's very stressful
and i'm watching porn so i said okay
this situation turns you on
is what do you mean i said well you told
me the reason you watch porn is because
it's like just a guy because you know
just a guy doing his thing it's sexual
and he understood from that question
that
my he understood my point from that
question that the reason he was watching
pornography was because he found himself
in a stressful situation
and he was using pornography or abusing
pornography to meet some emotional need
and that's where it gets wildly
destructive
did i answer your question yeah i guess
i guess what i'm trying to find out
is what is the negative impact so okay i
have some stats here
for teenagers right nine out of ten boys
are exposed to pornography before the
age of 18. i'm surprised it's nine out
of ten i figured be a hundred percent of
kids right
that are exposed to pornography six out
of ten girls are exposed to pornography
for 18. okay
on average a male's first experience to
pornography is at 12 years old okay
71 of teens have done something to hide
what they do online from their parents i
believe that teenage boys 12 to 17
have the highest risk of developing a
porn addiction right
okay then the next one says
uh i have hears from uh wives my husband
is addicted to porn
pornography addiction does not only
affect the addict and it can also
negatively impact the well-being of the
individual's wife or girlfriend
addiction can cause the following
feelings within the wife of a porn
addict
rejection betrayal depression
abandonment isolation
uh loneliness humiliation anger right so
did you like my my way of studying a
topic if i'm struggling with something
in my life i'm trying to raise money i
have no clue what the different controls
are
before i go and raise this you know next
money i got to find out what control so
i go read everything and anything i can
find on the topic if i'm struggling with
parenting a girl versus a boy i want to
go read everything i can on that topic
when you were going to the rabbit hole
did you yourself go out there and do a
ton of due diligence to see the effects
of
porn can have on men on singles on
married or was it just like
look i'm struggling with this i met with
my therapist and then i just wanted to
talk about it
did you do a lot of research and due
diligence so the research
for me came to addiction and that's
where i spent a lot of time and i i
looked at this very quickly as an
addiction as soon as i read
it i read a great book by patrick
harness called out of the shadows
and patrick harness talks about sex
addiction he's actually one who coined
the term
sex addiction not coined the term but he
was the first therapist
they call him like the father of sex
addiction recovery where he was the
first therapist to really talk out
talk about the possibility of someone
being able to be addicted to sex
some don't believe there could be an
addiction so as soon as i read that book
and i saw the
parallels in my life with what he was
talking about that became my obsession
my beca my obsession became
recovery from addiction versus how
destructive pornography is
for anyone else got it listen for me
it's that my motivation
and in terms of girls i mean what's the
likelihood
that i'm gonna hit on girls less i'm
going to approach them less i'm going to
interact with them less
all of those things is going to um in a
real human way
right because i have something easily
available to me
that met my need in some way so it
i can i can talk for hours about the way
it affected my life
i think some of these questions that
you're asking about
how large of a problem it is and how how
much it affects people
someone else is probably better suited
to answer to answer those questions
i only ask it because if i speak on a
top like let's just say everywhere i go
i get pulled over for different topics
if i'm a valet guy pull up valega will
get out and say he's italian he'll say
man i got to tell you
out of all the interviews of mobsters
which one do you like the most
is it samuel bulgarvan or is it frank
colada is it oscar goodman
so it starts a conversation then i get
hit up from emails from people from
sicily from people from all over the
world you should interview this russian
mobster you should interview this
albanian mobster and then i'll go into
bodybuilding and a bunch of people from
bodybuilding come to me
i just wonder if you talk about a topic
this sensitive as porn addiction did a
lot of doctors psychologists therapists
come up to you
send you research to say here's the
challenges and the reason why i ask this
question is because
i think this is as big of a deal as you
think it is
but i think the impact on this is very
massive for uh for the community for
somebody like yourself who's already
made an influence you got three million
people on this topic
i watch pamela anderson talk about porn
and
it was one of the most fascinating
interviews i saw with pamela anderson
so you know when you think about pamela
what do you think about you think about
baywatch you think about
who's the guy she was with what's the
guy's name she was with um i'm thinking
oh well i don't know what his name is
you know what i'm talking about the good
looking guy what's his name
tommy lee what's his name tommy lee so a
they're together and their video came
out and it was so public and all this
other stuff so
and then she had a son and then she
talked about in an interview where
look you know when you're going out
there meeting men and you're having sex
says it's starting to get annoying
because men think they have to have sex
with you
the way men have sex with women and porn
because they that's where they get their
education from so a lot of times that
becomes a form of education where single
men are thinking
hey that's what i need to do to go
please xyz
number two is you know when if you're
married and you're watching too much
porn it creates a distance between you
and your wife
almost because you know it's kind of
like man you know there's no way in the
world you can meet this expectation of
what i sign here so
anything below that is you know just not
going to turn me on the way xyz turned
me on in this movie that i watch or in
this
series that i watch i was just curious
to know if you haven't elaborated
on that please elaborate on that point
of
what's turning someone on because one of
one of the things
that impacted me towards the end i i
committed in uh
march of 2013 that's when i committed to
stop watching porn and it's been about
four and a half years since i've seen
anything so it took a few years zero
zero you haven't watched any for four
and a half years i haven't intentionally
went to watch porn in four and a half
years yeah it's sometimes hard not to
bump into things like you mentioned
right your employee opens a phone in
front of you
so if you had a streak going then that
wouldn't work so i'm specific about what
i mean i haven't intentionally gone to
to look at porn but i saw an interview
with the porn star
a couple months before my decision to
stop
and she spoke about walking in on her
boyfriend watching pornography
and right so she said her whole view of
pornography changed in that in style
right because until then she's like okay
i'm hotter than these other
girls that's the reason why everyone's
watching me
and uh you know makes sense right i'm
the hottest
they're less hot so watch me have sex
and here is a guy
here's a man the one man who i want to
have sex with and he's watching
pornography of other people and that's
when he that's when she realized for
herself that porn kind of operates on a
little bit of a different track
than the regular sex drive
in the sense that it's not just i'm more
attracted to this
so i want so i want the one that's most
attractive there's something about the
variety there's something about the
um it being as a not a human being
it being in an inanimate there's
something about being able to
watch anything that we are thinking
about that day right
etc etc that uh pushes us in that
direction or pulls us in that direction
and she said after that she was done
with porn she realized that
yeah what she's doing isn't helping
people it's not
you know it's i don't know some some
people say you know i watch porn with my
wife to kind of get myself
to get the engines revved and over there
she said hey this is something else
going on because
if it was just about that he'd be
sleeping with me and
in the in instead other people are
watching me
are watching me have sex and the person
who could is watching someone else have
sex
something not good is going on here it's
great perspective from somebody who's in
that field you walk in onto your man
watching porn of another girl while
you're
you're a porn star and you're watching a
very very uh interesting perspective
i'd be curious to know what the what her
name is i'd love to interview her myself
to see
what she can bring to the table so look
let's talk about this part i think the
one part with this
is it's such a sensitive topic that
you know sometimes when people talk
about this topic it almost comes across
as uh
uh uh i can't believe you do such a
thing and i can't believe you know it's
kind of like
looking down at people who have watched
it and then there's also another group
where
it's where it's what's the big deal you
know just
it's not a big deal just drop it versus
not realizing that you know just like a
guy is addicted to xanax or vicodin or
cocaine or pot or you know
heroin whatever maybe it's a similar
challenge and thing to get rid of the
difference is
if you want xanax you have to go to get
it from somebody for a couple dollars a
pop
if you want coke nose candy you got to
go find somebody to buy from
but if you want to you know porn you're
you're two seconds away from having it
the dealer sitting right in front of you
at any time
so especially for kids yeah right i mean
that's it's magnified for kids we do so
much to protect kids from alcohol from
everything under the sun and then what
do they have to do they have to check
mark that they're 18.
yeah and and uh uh it's just a crazy
question for you did your parents talk
to you about sex early on or no
no they didn't talk about sex early on
okay got it
uh uh neither did mine i mean my mother
would ask me in germany have you taken
science yet i said why do you keep
asking me if i've taken science here
like what are you asking me about
why i've taken signs yet walk me through
someone's watching this
okay right after they watch this
interview
they clear history because they don't
want to see that they're watching an
interview like this about porn because
they don't want anybody to know that
they're watching you know a
video with history something tells me
this interview the percentage of people
watching the entire interview is going
to be higher than usual because
they want to see exactly what things are
going to be said because i know
a lot of people struggle with this what
is the process i have it in front of me
but i'm curious
what process you took what was your
process
to go through drop in porn where for
four and a half years you haven't
intentionally watched any porn
what was the process you took that work
for you three components of the process
there was therapy well first before i go
into that it was whatever it takes
right it's if someone asked you what you
had to do in business
the real answer is i was willing to do
whatever it took and this is what it
happened to take for me so i want to
qualify that
it was 100 whatever it took i it was the
most important priority for me once i
noticed how much it was affecting my
life
and the the way i found out is trying to
stop doing doing it for a period of time
and i got at one point the first time i
tried to stop was 57 days i was feeling
freaking amazing so many parts of my
life getting better but on the other
hand
i was feeling amazing in the sense that
my feelings started coming up
right so like i started feeling better
and some of those feelings were
extremely uncomfortable feelings
that were coming up so when i became
better at feeling because some of the
porn
numbed so much of it so i started some
of the trauma some of the pain some of
the confusion
some of that started coming up as well
but in answer to your question
there was therapy there was support
groups and then a little bit of help
from technology
that was kind of the three-pronged
approach that i
took to stopping to watch porn can you
tell me support groups and what
technology
yeah so technology they were at the time
i used something like k9 browser
and then the general stuff on on the
iphone when i got an iphone i'm sure
there are better stuff now
i know there's i've i've worked with
covenant eyes
covenant eyes i think is a really good
one um covenant
eyes uses a uh it's kind of like a um
a mentor relationship where i've been on
the other side of that so i didn't know
this software when i was trying to stop
but the the problem with using something
like canine browser or some of the other
stuff
is that there are always ways around it
whereas
covenant eyes kind of screenshots at
random times and it gives someone on the
other end
hey the guy didn't use his phone for a
long period of time
or here are some snapshots
versus you know for example i can be on
instagram that's not picked up by the
browser but i'm watching stuff that may
as well be porn something like covenant
eyes will see that they'll take pictures
and then you'll have a conversation with
your accountability partner so imagine
one of your employees came to you and
said
patrick i'm struggling watching porn
will you be my accountability partner on
covenant eyes and then it
it'll send you reports and have that
conversation so there's a lot of
different technology out there
i used k9 browser and the regular apple
stuff just to limit it
and the reason is this isn't a fail-safe
i don't have anything today on my phones
just to be clear what it does is it just
gives you a space between stimulus and
response
and for me that i've sat down on my
computer so many times
i see the google screen and i'm already
for years when i saw that google image
that was a trigger for me so i needed
something to block all google images
even on my work computer for several
years now that trigger has weakened so
one was technology but again that's just
to put a small gap
support groups i use the 12 steps i'm a
big proponent of the 12 steps
obviously there's there's an anonymous
factor to the 12 steps because
in the 12 steps no one wants to come and
say um
or not so much the 12 steps but the
specific programs within the 12 steps so
i won't name the program
that i'm a part of and the reason for
the anonymous factor is
you know let's say next week i slip on
porn or i'm found in a strip club or
something else
someone doesn't say oh look it doesn't
work it does work
but i don't want to be the poster child
there are no poster childs for
you any of these programs and then
therapy really deep dive in therapy and
therapy means
everything you can imagine plus you you
know uh uh
are you close to both your parents mom
and dad yeah i
am you're you're my mom you're a very
valued guy
what did you pick up from your mom and
what did you pick up from your dad
because you seem like a very
raised properly values and principal
type of guy
thanks i appreciate that uh both my pet
you know we didn't grow up with much
uh both my parents decided to become
more religious in their late 20s early
30s
so they they brought us up with religion
but in a way that was not
um indoctrinated to them but chosen for
them
so i think that was a little bit
different they both chose it was a very
religious life a very acidic life i
don't
live that way today but i saw that
my dad was very involved in the
community he helped out in pretty much
anything he could we didn't grow up with
much money i was one of nine
kids my dad was a government employee my
mom was a part-time teacher
but i saw them help people and i saw
them uh
i saw them do what they could to to be
better people and be better people
within the community within the
community
so well respect i mean it's felt it's
it's felt
you you um i'm in a business of reading
people it's what i do for a living many
times people think i'm like an
entrepreneur or
insurance or finance i'm in the business
of reading people that's what i get paid
to do
and i've been doing that for 20 years
and i'm not on all the time but i'm
can get a pretty good read for folks so
so
flip the question for you now on you
know
raising kids do you have any kids yet or
no you have three kids
yeah you have three kids are you trying
to beat your parents record or no
no but i have a two-year-old a
one-year-old and a newborn so i'm we're
moving quickly
that that then that means that you're
using your addiction in the right way
you you're using it with one family and
you're building your kids
uh by the way patrick a lot of people
who are porn addicts don't have a lot of
sex
with their wives so i know that
i know that yeah i know that it's so
funny i got a call
very random call hey how many times do
you and your wife have sex
i said what do you think and you know
it's like well we only have sex once a
month
i'm like what we don't have sex once a
month why
i don't know it's just once a month so
and that's not one person or two or
three that's many people who have asked
that weird question and for whatever
reason that question is being asked a
lot
in the last five years but here's a
question for you just out of curiosity
we're both parents you got three kids
two one and one on the way i got three
and one on the way
a newborn that's right i got a nine
seven or four and one on the way okay
what are you planning on like the
approach you're going to take with this
with your kids have you thought about it
have you sat there and said you know
when my kids come up this age this is
how i'm going to speak to them about
this have you processed that at all
i'll tell i'll tell you something that
happened a few weeks ago
but not necessarily not for my kids i've
thought about it for my kids but i got a
lot of nephews and nieces
a few weeks ago i come downstairs with a
t-shirt it's a t-shirt from fight the
new drug that says porn kills love
and i don't think about wearing around
my kids because my kids don't read yet
but my nephew was over
and my nephew was um two nephews
one is ten one at nine and the nine year
old
says what's porn when he sees my t-shirt
that's a good question by the way so at
first i i turned kind of red i was like
oh [ __ ] i avoid the wrong t-shirt
i wait a little bit i ran upstairs i
changed my shirt
and then uh funny i actually left i went
to a
i said i have to think about it let me
answer you another time and
i actually went to a 12-step meeting
after that and while i was sitting there
i was thinking saying hey he saw the
porn kills love and he asked about porn
and i got a little bit ashamed
but if you look at those stats that's
the average age that kids look at porn
wow and that's what i told this mom i
said that
you know yes i probably wore the wrong
shirt right
around kids but on the other hand i
think that a conversation has to happen
and that's that that's what i have
that's what i think about with my kids
there's nothing you can do
technology-wise
to stop your kids from watching porn yes
you want to have blockers you want to
have filters
but what are you going to do when
they're at a friend's house and you
think you're going to tell them they're
not going to have a phone
then they're going to feel like the kid
that's left out so the only
the only thing we could do sort of you
know if we want to take on the fight
with the government and
everything else with the porn industry
there's some people doing that but short
of that if the industry looks like it
does now
and it's as accessible then we got to be
able to sit down and have conversations
and they know they can
they can talk to us well i can tell you
there's uh three types of audiences that
are gonna watch this video this
interview one is gonna say
i don't struggle with porn great then
share this with somebody who you know
that may struggle with porn
then there's gonna be an audience that's
gonna say yeah i i watch porn but i
don't consider myself an addict and i
think you guys are crazy if you think
it's a big deal
it's just watching a movie it's not a
big deal and they don't think they have
a challenge no problem then there's
gonna be the third kind
that's gonna say you know what i may
have a porn
addiction i may have a challenge that i
can't stop consuming the content
we are gonna put the link to everything
ellie just shared with us whether it's
covenant eyes
whether it's the book he talked about
out of shadows by
patrick j carnes we'll put that below as
well and i'll put the link below as well
to fight the new drug for you to go do
your own due diligence
if this matters to you and if you uh
want to get a hold of
ellie as well we'll put the link below
for you to get a hold of ellie ellie
thank you so much for your time this was
very helpful
appreciate it patrick have a good
everybody thank you so much
take care sensitive topic but millions
deal with it and if you're somebody that
watched the entire interview i'd be
curious to know what you took away from
it maybe you comment anonymously maybe
you comment proudly and say
here's where i'm at but definitely if
you're someone that
relates to ellie we have a links below
to everything he spoke about and if you
want to watch another interview that has
to do regarding porn addiction
and dopamine by a doctor who does this
professionally click over to watch the
interview with daniel
lieberman take care everybody bye-bye